with Apple's new 15-inch MacBook Air you
can get a big display and save 800
compared to the 16 inch MacBook Pro but
if you make that choice what exactly are
you giving up well we're gonna find out
in this video by comparing everything
between them including the designs
portability ports displays speakers
webcam performance and more right off
the bat you can see that the 16 inch is
just a little bit bigger in terms of the
display I've got to say this 15 inch is
really impressive it's like the perfect
size but before I dig deeper into the
displays I want to close them down and
compare the portability as you can see
there is a massive difference in
thickness the new 15 inch air is just so
incredibly thin it feels almost
impossible in your hands and in terms of
the actual footprint you can see the 16
inch is a bit bigger all around so it's
not that big of a difference but if we
put it up kind of to the edges you can
see right there that yes it is quite a
bit bigger on the side you can see that
the ports are very similar at least on
the left we have Max save three two
Thunderbolts and the 16 inch actually
has the headphone jack whereas the
MacBook Air has it on the other side but
it is bare no other ports the six inch
gives you an extra Thunderbolt an SD
card slot and HDMI 2.1 so if you really
care about the ports for a productivity
work or anything else the 16 inch is the
way to go now even though this is a 15
inch Class laptop it only supports One
external display which is very sad
whereas the 16 inch supports three
external displays and now that they're
opened up you can see that they're
extremely similar we have the same
general layout however the MacBook Pro
has black all around the keyboard which
looks really cool and unique the track
pads look almost identical no difference
is really there but one thing you will
notice is that the 16 inch has speaker
grilles on the side with a six speaker
system compared to the MacBook Air which
doesn't not but it also has six speakers
so let's do a speaker comparison
[Music]
wow guys that was a huge difference even
though the 15 inch sounds so much better
than the 13-inch M2 this is just on a
whole nother level the sound is more
full it's louder deeper bass everything
about it Clarity everything sounds
better than the 15 inch for sure now
getting into the display differences we
know this is a 15 inch MacBook Air
compared to 16 inch but this actually
has a 15.3 inch display compared to 16.2
so less than one inch difference but the
really nice thing about the 16 inch is
the 3.5 K resolution compared to only
2.8k so it is going to be more sharp but
just physically looking at them directly
one thing that instantly stands out to
me is the difference in bezel width
right away you can see that the 15 inch
bezels are a little bit chunky compared
to the 16 inch looks super super slim
but what am I my favorite features on
the 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros is 120
hertz Pro motion technology which you
can't get on the 15 inch that basically
means that you get 120 hertz smooth
refresh rate compared to just 60 hertz
on the 15. and another unique feature
this
MacBook Pro gets is the xdr display
which means you can display HDR content
you could do editing with it you could
watch HDR movies it basically goes up to
1600 nits of peak brightness for HDR
content which looks a lot better than
the MacBook Air which is limited to 500
nits on top of that you also have
improved contrast ratio which makes the
content and colors really really pop but
the downside is that sometimes you do
get some halo effect and now let's
compare the webcams because one
interesting thing is that we saw the
15-inch MacBook Air had better quality
than the 13 inch and they're supposed to
be the same so you guys let me know how
this looks compared to this 16 inch and
here we are on the 16 inch MacBook Pro
to me it looks pretty similar you guys
will probably be able to tell yourselves
as well as the microphone difference so
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you want a really good
quality webcam you're gonna have to go
with something like this the new insta
360 link from our sponsor insta360. it's
an AI powered 4K webcam all you do to
set it up is you plug it in you open up
this little clip right here pop it right
onto the top and check this out this
looks absolutely fantastic with 4K
quality from its half inch sensor take a
look at that side by side compared to
the MacBook it completely destroys them
but what makes this webcam really
special is that it's actually running on
a gimbal so you can move around and it
follows you literally tracks you around
the room that basically Works using
their AI tracking algorithm which also
supports gestures so you can turn off
auto tracking by showing your palm and
you can also do things like zoom in and
put it into whiteboard mode it also has
other cool features like overhead mode
as you can see here so you can maybe be
working on something and showing
somebody else but my favorite thing
about this that you can can't do on a
MacBook ever is all of this
customization settings right here so you
can adjust the compensation make it a
little bit brighter make it less adjust
the white balance to exactly what you
want so go ahead and check out the insta
360 link 4K webcam using the link in the
description below and now let's finally
get into performance which is the
biggest reason why people would buy the
16 inch MacBook Pro in the first place
starting off they both have 16 gigs of
RAM the 15 inch is upgraded and the SSD
as well both with 512 gigabytes of
course the 15 inch has the M2 Chip with
the full 8 cores and the 10 core GPU
whereas the 16 inch has the full 12 core
M2 Pro chip and 19 GPU cores and now
with that said let's run the CPU
Benchmark and while this is running keep
in mind that 800 difference between the
two however you could get the 16 inch on
sale right now for a couple hundred
bucks off which is really nice using the
link in the description so it really
only becomes a five to six hundred
dollar difference as you can see in
terms of single core performance they're
basically neck and neck the same because
they have the same M2 cores but for the
multi-core the 16 inch is 43 faster
which is a pretty big difference and now
for the Metal Graphics test it's an even
bigger difference 78 faster on the M2
Pro 16 inch MacBook Pro and now let's
move on to web design using figma now
this is a project sent over from 500
designs a really awesome studio in
California we're going to start off with
a zoom test basically zooming in and
seeing how fast it loads and responds we
have a delay right there let's see how
long it takes
there you go it is now sharp let's do
the same thing on this one
honestly it looks like it took around
the same time on both of them but now
it's actually export these selected 12
layers and see which one gets done
faster and there you go it's done the
six inch finish in a minute and 35
seconds whereas the 15-ish took a little
bit longer a minute and 48 but honestly
for web design that's not that big of a
difference I'd rather just save the cash
now as far as SSD speeds they are
basically the same because both these
use the same ssds but if you buy the 256
gig base model that thing is about half
the speed and the multitasking is worse
as well so make sure enable those
notifications if you guys want to see us
compare a 1300 air compared to this 1700
run and now I'm running Cinemax R23 to
compare the CPU performance Under full
load the thing
you guys that compare to having dual
fans on the 16 inch and as you see even
after about 30 seconds we're already at
107 degrees Celsius on the air where
this one it is much cooler and we have
86.41 for the ear and 14
728 for the 16 inch pro that's a
difference of 70 percent now I'm running
a 10 minute throttling test because for
longer tasks the Macbook will slow down
even more as you guys can see we're
already going from the base 3.2
gigahertz to slowing down and after
about 10 minutes we will actually uh get
under three gigahertz and our wattage
will go down to about 14 compared to
this one which uses a lot more power 36
Watts it's going to stay completely flat
and consistent and if you're worried
about the fans here being loud they're
not this is a silent machine and most of
the times the fans stay off the test is
almost done and pulling out my thermal
cam you guys can see that the 16 inches
hotter spot is on the screen where the
exhaust vents bring the sauce up and if
we look at the keyboard I saw there for
a second 42 degrees was the hottest part
compared to the air where that heat is
higher 46 and it spreads out a lot more
so on the keyboard and what happens over
time is the whole bottom gets hot and
then the city computer will actually
slow down even more to prevent you from
burning your lap and now the scores are
7402 for the air and 14 670 for the 16
inch and that's not a big difference
compared to before so with CPU tests
even in the air throttles it doesn't
slow down that much but what about
graphics for this I'm going to run 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme unlimited mode so
the resolutions don't play into it and
look at that we have 41.2 FPS compared
to 77.8 that is 89
faster as far as gaming graphics
performance
um that is crazy and this is the sure
test now let's go ahead and do the 20
minute stress test to see how the air
holds up being fanless and look at that
guys we have a score of 5505 compared to
twelve thousand six hundred and one that
is close to two and a half times better
performance on the 16 inch because if
you look here during the stress test the
performance is basically flat whereas in
the air it starts dipping down uh around
this five six minute mark and it gets
worse
um so basically here you lose about 20
percent of the performance once it heats
up and that is a massive difference now
in terms of xcode programming
performance we have our Benchmark here
and I'm going to run it in the terminal
command to make sure everything is fair
and that took 120 seconds on the air in
just 75 seconds on the 16 inch M2 Pro
that is a massive difference but what
about for music production I have logic
pro opened up right here I already did
the test because it takes a long time
and the air in the New Logic Benchmark
handled 85 tracks whereas the 16-inch
Pro did 180. that's you know pretty much
double or slightly more than double of
what it can handle you can look up the
test for yourself but it's clear to see
that the 16 inch pro is way more
powerful if you need that now for photo
editors I have Adobe Lightroom classic
opened up right here and it does a great
job using both the CPU and the GPU now a
lot of things you're going to do you
won't notice a difference but some
things like the new AI noise reduction
the 16 inch pro is much quicker taking
just 42 seconds compared to a minute and
13 seconds and I'm exporting 50 42
megapixel raw files to jpeg they all had
Corrections on there and the 16 inches
definitely going ahead wow guys that
took a minute and two seconds for the
pro compared to 2 min minutes and 40
seconds for the air now I did this in a
previous video with 500 images and the
air really slowed down it was like a 25
minute render and so the whole thing
came kind of to a crawl so if you deal
with a lot of photos man that is a crazy
difference now for video editing with
Final Cut both these laptops do a killer
job even with 4K prores raw standard
footage it's the only way you get crazy
for example I have AK raw right here and
the graphics are being maxed out but
most people will edit regular 4K and
here I have film grain applied I have
multiple Luts the ear has no issues with
this only with the pro you have a little
bit more Graphics overhead to add more
effects now exporting this believe it or
not but the times are exactly the same
because these use the same encoders it's
only when you start doing heavier
projects like this 4K prores raw black
magic raw or special animations where
the 16 inch starts moving ahead you guys
could see that it is rolling much faster
here 54 seconds compared to a minute and
40 and this is a five minute project now
a minute 40 is still very fast so I
would say that if you do video editing
unlike photo editing for a lot of people
the air is just fine and with that said
the 16 inch pro just got a low battery
notification let's go and check it out
we are at 10 battery life and in terms
of the air here we are at 31 so even
though Apple rates the 16 inch better if
you're doing heavy tasks the air uses a
lot less power so you will get better
battery life now if you're doing very
simple stuff then the pro will be just
slightly ahead but they are fairly close
so to answer the original question is it
worth spending the extra 700 bucks a lot
of people find themselves in this cat
category well if you've really pushed
your machines you saw that in a lot of
those tests the 16-inch Pro demolished
the air especially for longer tasks
where throttles down and Graphics is a
big difference but a lot of people that
have spent the extra for the ports for
the better screen they've said that they
ended up not needing it so I would keep
that in mind if you if those things are
nice things to have but you love the
thinness and you don't currently do very
tough things I would still say that the
air is a great deal you'll be happy with
it and it holds its value well so you
can sell it and upgrade if you want to
in the future if you really have that
need let us know your thoughts down
below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos over there and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
thank you